CHET HAASE: Hello and welcome
to the Android Fireside Chat,
another edition of this thing.
You will notice that there are
a lot of people onstage up here.
This is probably the most
they have for any session ever
at I/O. In fact, it's so
many that we're in danger
of violating the fire code.
We may need to ask
the audience to leave.
We're going to do a
seriously quick introduction
of the people on stage,
so you get an idea of,
A, who they are, B, more
importantly, what they actually
do and what answers they may
actually be able to provide.
Starting with me,
I'm just the emcee.
I don't matter.
I'm Chet.
Brian, go.
BRIAN KARLSTROM:
Brian Karlstrom,
programming languages, Java,
[INAUDIBLE] host, and Kotlin.
WALLE: Walle, windows
and activities.
RASHAD: Rashad, Android media.
TOR NORBYE: Tor
Norbye, Android Studio.
ROMAIN GUY: Romain
Guy, graphics.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Xavier
Ducrohet, developer tools.
DAN SANDLER: Dan
Sandler, system UI.
RACHEL GARB: Rachel
Garb, user experience.
BEN POLESZ: Ben
Polesz, framework.
AURASH MAHBOD: Aurash Mahbod,
PlayStore app and Android apps.
TOM KINCH: Tom Kinch,
Android Tech Support, Library
and Espresso.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE],
Android Security.
TIM MURRAY: Tim Murray,
Android Performance.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Steph
Cuthbertson, Android IDEs
and frameworks.
DAVE BURKE: Dave Burke,
pure Android overhead.
YIGIT BOYAR: Yigit Boyar,
architecture components.
MAXIM SHAFIROV:
I'm a guest here.
I'm from JetBrains.
I'm CEO of JetBrains,
Maxim Shafirov.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM POWELL: Adam
Powell, framework.
MIKE CLERON: Mike Cleron,
lesser Android overhead.
DIANNE HACKBORN:
Dianne Hackborn,
manage the framework team.
CHET HAASE: All right,
so everybody got that?
Excellent.
Moving on, we have a
few slides to cover
a little bit of content before
we get into the meat of it.
So-- no, actually
let's just get into it.
So here's the way it works.
I'll ask a couple, so you
understand what this is.
You're going to ask questions,
and we're going to--
we may evade the answers.
We don't know.
It depends on what you ask.
The ground rule is we don't
really talk about-- no,
we don't talk about futures.
So if you say, yeah,
but what is Google
going to do a year
from now on this thing?
Then we will say, thank
you for the question.
Would somebody else
like to ask one?
Just so you know, when we
say that, there's a reason.
But I will show you how this
works for a couple of things.
So we trolled Twitter and G
Plus to get some questions, sort
of pre-roll some
topics, just to find out
what the community would
like to know about, people
that weren't necessarily here.
One of the things that came up--
I will summarize the
several comments on Twitter
that essentially
came down to what
about adopting Kotlin as
a language for Android?
Check.
MAXIM SHAFIROV: Done.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: All right, here's
another one that came up.
A few different comments
phrased in different ways,
but essentially boils down
to a two-part question.
How does Fuchsia
relate to Android?
Dave?
DAVE BURKE: How do
you spell Fuchsia?
Fuchsia is early stage,
experimental project.
We actually have lots of cool
early projects at Google.
I think what's interesting
here is it's open source.
So people can see it
and comment on it.
Like lots of early
stage projects,
it's going to probably
pivot and morph.
There are some really
smart people on it,
people we've worked
with who are great,
and so we're kind of
exciting to see what happens.
But it's definitely an
independent project to Android.
Yeah, that's basically it.
CHET HAASE: Thank you.
OK, we're going to ask another
question here, but we could--
multi-process this thing.
People should be
lining up at the mics
if they want to ask
questions, and if nobody
wants to ask questions,
it's fine by us.
The session will end very early.
So second part of two-part
question for Mike.
How does Flutter
relate to Android?
MIKE CLERON: Well, let's
see, we have pretty much
the entire Android team.
What do you all think is the
best framework for Android?
Is it Android?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Usually.
MIKE CLERON: Yeah, so we kind
of like our own stuff, but the--
Android has always
been pretty open.
It's our core principle.
So the better answer is
use whatever works for you.
We try to make stuff
that works for you.
We hope you like it.
We hope you use it.
If you do, that's great.
If you find something
that you like better,
then that is just
something to shoot for.
CHET HAASE: All right, we
have people at the mics now.
So why don't we go to a
mic over on the left there.
AUDIENCE: My question is, for people that are starting with Android,
do you recommend them to use Kotlin or Java?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Great question.
I think one of the things
we made clear in the keynote
and we are trying
to say very clearly
is we are embracing Kotlin.
Someone can hug Max
there if you want.
Yeah, hug Max.
We're embracing Kotlin, embrace.
But we're also doubling
down simultaneously
on our existing
languages, and we're
very open about that in the
keynote with investments
in, for instance, Java
8 language features.
Lambdas are my personal
favorite in Java C Compiler.
We also made extensive
improvements in APIs.
Again, the Java.time API
is my personal favorite,
and there was a phalanx
of improvements there.
We also made extensive
improvements in C++,
and you'll continue to see
investment in Kotlin and also
investment in our existing
programming languages.
In fact, very
specifically Dave has
increased the size of the
teams in all of those areas.
So it's not an either/or for us.
It truly is an and.
So we really do believe
that for developers
who want to stay with the
Java programming language,
it is a wonderful language.
I've told people when
I studied CS at Brown,
it was the first language that
I learned and it is wonderful.
That said, for those who
would like to try Kotlin,
it is quite a beautiful
language, and a lot of us
here have tried it and
think it's quite wonderful.
CHET HAASE: So if
I could rephrase,
that was either one should work.
Is that--
[APPLAUSE]
Did I catch the essence of that?
You could try either one, yeah.
I'm sorry, you want to find
some more words for that,
we could-- go ahead,
go ahead, go ahead.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: It's
a good thing they cut me off
in the keynote, huh?
CHET HAASE: All right,
I think we got it.
Thank you.
Let's go over there.
AUDIENCE: We've heard a lot at I/O about features
like the new Assistant and similar
that require turning on location history and search history
and a lot of other data collections,
what are the options or alternatives
for people that want those capabilities
that want to maintain their privacy
and not report a ton of history?
CHET HAASE: You could turn it
on on your friend's devices.
Otherwise--
BEN POLESZ: To be
perfectly honest,
we're not on those
teams, so that's
why we're kind of
looking at each other.
We do really think that
privacy is a control that you
should have, and you still have
that in all these services.
I think you're asking
for those teams
to support the new services
they're introducing
and then not require location
history or other things.
Part of what makes
those features good
is to use those services.
If they're having a chat
of their own like this,
I would ask you to ask them.
But we are ensuring that
you always have the choice.
It may not be the choice
that you necessarily
want of fine-grained
choices within,
but we do think you
should have the visibility
to know what's on and
have a control in the OS
to turn it on or turn it off.
CHET HAASE: Next, you, sir.
AUDIENCE: Could you tell what you're doing
at a high level [with Treble]
to ensure that the implementation
from some of the OEM partners don't break,
either intentionally or not,
some of the things
you're going to do
in bringing forth new versions of the OS?
DAVE BURKE: Yeah,
so I actually did
have Project Treble
as part of my keynote,
but we didn't have
enough time, number one.
Number two is it's a very device
manufacturer focused project.
And so we thought we might
bore you all a little bit.
But since you've asked,
I can bore you now.
Bring up the teleprompter.
No, I'm joking.
So Project Treble--
actually if you
ask a lot of people around
here who worked on it,
they'll tell you it was
a huge amount of work,
and they're still angry at me.
Rashad is nodding his head.
He's so pissed off because
the amount of work that went
into media framework was huge.
But basically what we did was
we created a foundation layer
to Android, a very formal--
we call vendor
interface, and it's
analogous to the Developer API.
So today we have
Developer API and we
have CTS test to test it.
The idea being you
write an application
that runs on any hardware.
We've introduced a new vendor
interface at the bottom.
Everything south of
the vendor interface
is silicon specific
and hardware specific.
And then we have VTS tests that
test that vendor interface.
So the idea is
when the P release
comes along, if you're a
device maker, you take P
and it will run on top of
your vendor implementation
from today's O device
that you build, say.
And the whole reason
for that is we
want to make it easier and
faster for device makers
to update devices,
because if it's faster,
they'll get updates
out more quickly.
If it costs less,
they'll do more updates.
So that's the whole
premise of it.
It's a huge, huge change.
We have a very formal layer.
I can talk about it more.
But one of the things
that kind of-- it's
kind of analogous to Kotlin.
With Kotlin, like last year,
somebody grabbed the mic
and said, hey, can
we have Kotlin?
And everyone put their hands
up, and so we gave you Kotlin.
Treble, you ask, we deliver.
Not really.
For Treble, it was actually
the silicon vendors
and the device makers
who were asking us,
how do you reduce the cost?
Because today when you
build an Android device,
a lot of the silicon
and device specific code
is intermixed with a
framework and the core OS.
And then every time we
change the operating system,
they have to rework that code.
And so they asked us how
can we make it better.
And so we came up with treble.
But yeah, it's a huge change.
Probably the biggest
re-architecture
of Android since it started.
It was an enormous
amount of work.
And thank you to
all my colleagues
who hate me for implementing it.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes, so that stage
was a huge amount of work.
I just want to make
sure you understand
there's a lot of engineers at
Google who are not here today,
they're not here at I/O. They've
been working incredibly hard.
They had to go through, like,
millions of lines of code,
touch lines of code they
had never seen before.
One girl might seem like--
I think almost lost
it working on this.
So you should cheer them because
it's a huge amount of work.
You'll never see an API.
You'll never see tools.
But it's going to make
Android better in the future.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: If we tried to bring
any more engineers up on stage,
the producers would
have killed us.
So there was a follow-up
question about Treble
in Twitter--
on Twitter.
So I was going to
ask that one, which
was, the dark side
of Treble on devices
launched with O but DP1
running with Treble on existing
devices--
OK, that wasn't a complete
sentence, but this is Twitter.
So the question is, will devices
that get updated to O also
get Treble?
DAVE BURKE: Right, so one
of the challenges of doing
this huge re-architecture
is that if we
did it sort of blindly, we'd
actually slow down adoption
to O because there would
be a lot of work to do.
And so we wanted to try not
to slow down the short term
to speed up in the long term.
So if you have an
existing device--
you being a device maker--
on N and you want
to an update to O,
the Treble requirements
aren't applied to you.
However, if you're
a new device--
if you're a device maker
building a new device,
then you have to comply
to the O architecture.
So that's sort of how it works.
And then what we did,
just to prove it all out,
was we decided to treat the 2016
Pixel as a new device for O.
And so this is fully
what we call Treble-ized,
which means that all of
that vendor implementation
is implemented in
a separate process,
and it's built like you would
rebuild-- we basically rebuilt
the system on Pixel, and we did
that because we wanted to prove
it out end to end, so
that devices coming later
in the year, new
devices on O will be
able to sail plainly through.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys and gals
and everyone in between.
My question is
when you use your Android
phone, what do you really hate?
And why haven't
you fixed it yet?
[APPLAUSE]
ROMAIN GUY: I have one.
I really hate the colors,
but I'm fixing this in O.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE CLERON: And I really
hate notifications,
some that come from
nameless applications
from my own company, and
that gentleman over there,
along with members of his
team, are fixing that this time
with notification channels.
DAVE BURKE: I really hate the
lock contention and system
server.
So we'll fix that
for the next race.
Seriously I obsess about lock
contention and system server.
It bugs me.
CHET HAASE: Anyone
else have a confession?
BEN POLESZ: I'm
going to go with--
this group should
know, but battery life.
And the reason we don't break
it is because all of you.
We have to-- keeping you alive
but keeping battery life alive
at the same time.
CHET HAASE: All right,
that'll do for a sample.
How about over here?
AUDIENCE: Knowing what you
know now, and especially
with some of the
changes in Android O,
would you still implement
the same four application
interfaces such as
Activities, Service,
and Intents, in a new
operating system?
DIANNE HACKBORN: You know,
that really depends on--
I don't regret the
stuff we did, and I
think you could always
make improvements,
but if you're looking for
things I would change,
probably the big
things is stuff that we
did that allowed
applications to do too much.
Like, a big one for me
is the settings provider
accessed allowing applications
to change system settings.
I wish we had never
done that and just
made sure we had
clear, controlled APIs
for them to do things.
So those were the
kind of things that
are really hard after the
fact once applications
start doing things, to try to
get them back under control.
And those are the main things
I think I wish we did--
places I wish we'd
done better at.
CHET HAASE: Next.
AUDIENCE: My question is to do
with the blocking of broadcast
declared in manifests
in O. In a session this afternoon,
Dan said that user choice is the essence of Android,
so why won't you let users whitelist apps?
DIANNE HACKBORN:
Well, I mean, that--
the Mathis thing is-- that's
not really about users.
That's about developers.
And there's a lot
of things that we
don't allow applications
to do because it's
better for the overall
device behavior.
And actually Mathis
receivers is actually
one of the things that--
speaking of things
we regret doing,
I think if I had
done again like--
having that be so
easy to make things
that you can launch
applications like that
was clearly a big
mistake that we made,
and we didn't really at the time
realize that once it's there
and you have, like, 100
applications on your phone
all listening to this broadcast,
the kind of hell that's
going to break loose on the
device when that happens.
So I really think
that that's something
that we need to really put
brakes on and get control back
over the device and switch
to more controlled things
like JobScheduler.
MIKE CLERON: And if I could
add to that on user choice,
we announced--
I hope we announced-- that
we have two billion users.
If not, I just announced it.
And that's a reasonable fraction
of the world's population.
And so we think about
literally everyone
when we're designing it, and
there's a lot of questions
that it's just really hard
to put in front of users
and expect them to make
scalable decisions,
especially when applications
put something in their face that
says, hey, just
please turn us on,
it'll make this feature better.
And it's not the applications
are doing anything wrong,
usually, as their
individual choice.
But if 100
applications all asked
the same thing
and the user says,
well, I said yes
to the first 70,
I'll say yes to
the next 30, then
they end up with
an unusable device.
So we have to balance user
choice, which you're right,
that is one of our
core principles.
We have to balance that
with making devices
that literally anyone can
administer and manage and still
have a good experience.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I
can add more to that
too because on top of
that, there is user choice.
You can say, I want
to-- if you really
want to listen to things going
on, do a foreground service,
and the user knows that you're
running all the time now.
And I think that part of this is
actually having the user choice
being quite clear to the user.
It's clear to the
user-- it's, like, oh,
this application is just running
all the time because I really
care about it, so
it's OK with me,
and I will allow it to do that
versus subtleties about, well,
OK, I have this choice to
allow it to run sometimes
in the background, but I don't
really know what that does
and I don't realize that
when I do this a lot--
with a lot of applications ,
that actually there's a lot
of stuff going on in the
background I'm not aware of.
So I think it's--
we learn to-- with foreground
services, to having that UI
and having these kind
of clear lock things
you go into, like, oh,
I've decided do this,
so this has a lot of
implications of what you do
that the user understands
all that stuff together,
as that's a good-- they
can make that choice
between those things.
But having kind of subtle
choices about this or that
and it's not really clear
what it means, really
doesn't leave the
user with much choice
because they don't
really understand.
ADAM POWELL: I think that
finally that kind of shows
another principle that's
coming to the forefront in more
recent versions
of Android, which
is that when the
user makes a choice,
we want to make sure that
their-- choice to allow the app
to do something, we want to
make sure that that's something
that the user can actually see
the effects of and make sure
that they can kind of
audit that behavior as they
use the device.
So I think that, as Dianne
said, the foreground service
notification really does kind
of provide that visibility when
an app is running
in the background.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
A little different topic.
So we'll take one from
online for Rachel, I believe.
Is material design
done, or do you
see it growing and evolving?
RACHEL GARB: The work is
never done with design,
and I think that you probably
have a lot of other things--
other patterns that you would
like to see and have supported
for your apps.
So the material
team, they're growing
and they're investing
heavily in this space.
This was an offshoot of Android.
The material team started
out very small in Android,
and then it grew so big that
it is a completely different
department.
So yeah, I don't
think they're sitting
around twiddling their thumbs.
They're definitely doing a
lot to evolve the language.
AUDIENCE: Designers design.
DAN SANDLER: And
in particular they
just launched a bunch of code.
One of the great things about
having a separate department
for material is that they
have now the capacity
to bring on more prototypers,
more software engineers.
So if you go to
material.io, you'll
see that they've got a
bunch of new components
available for various
different platforms
to make it easier to
integrate the stuff
that has evolved in material
over the last couple of years.
So I think you can look
at their work product
along a number of
different axes and see
that material design is
alive and well and continuing
to evolve.
RACHEL GARB: And to see all that
stuff, you go to material.io,
lots of good stuff
there, resources, tools,
good articles.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
How about there?
AUDIENCE: Like everyone
else, I'm really excited
to have the support and encouragement for application development in Kotlin.
I'm wondering if that same
support and encouragement will
extend to Gradle Script Kotlin when it's released,
probably later in the year.
ROMAIN GUY: You mean
to write build files?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, to build files
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah,
yeah, we do plan
to support it as soon as it's
finished on the [INAUDIBLE]
side.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
How about here?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I have
a question on Kotlin.
For third-party
frameworks, are you
going to need to add anything,
like a bridging header,
as you do in Swift
to Objective C
to support Java projects
in Kotlin project
and the other way around? Are we going to need
to add any bridging
in an Android project
to use a Java framework or
Java third-party framework?
ADAM POWELL: No
I don't think so.
Next.
MAXIM SHAFIROV: So Kotlin has
some kind of a standard library
which is about 600 kilobytes.
So that's the only
thing you need to add.
CHET HAASE: Next.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE] So Tim [Murray]
showed us how to use
Systrace to profile our apps and in Tor's session today we saw CPU monitoring.
I'd like to know how these compare and contrast, and what are the values of each?
TIM MURRAY: Cage fight.
So Systrace gets all of its
data from the Linux kernel.
It doesn't really do anything
with your application directly.
It's not going to go and see
what functions take a long time
or anything like that.
It's just going to say, hey,
your app was running here,
and then it stopped
running here.
That's all it knows.
The CPU Profiler in Android
Studio, on the other hand,
will actually sample the
runtime of your application
and tell you, hey,
you're spending
50 milliseconds in this
function and four milliseconds
in this function and
things like that.
That means that the CPU Profiler
has higher overhead, which
means it can perturb the results
of your performance testing.
But it gives you
greater visibility
into your application.
So my general
recommendation would
be use Systrace to get
a general idea of how
your application runs
because you will probably
spot a lot of problems there.
Once you have some idea
of what's taking too long,
you can use the CPU
Profiler to get a closer
look inside your application.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
CHET HAASE: Tor,
did that cover it?
TOR NORBYE: That sounds good.
CHET HAASE: No rebuttal?
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, I
mean, the CPU Profiler
has a low overhead
mode until you start
recording actual sampling.
So you can use it
initially as well,
but Systrace obviously does
more whole system tracing.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I believe we have not heard much
about data binding this week,
and I wonder if that's
still a technology we
should be continued to adopt.
CHET HAASE: Yigit.
YIGIT BOYAR: Yes,
actually so we talk
[INAUDIBLE] we ship a
sample application that
uses data binding.
So we're still working on that.
Tools are still working
on that, right, Tor?
TOR NORBYE: Yes.
No, we should.
We have a lot of other
things we're working on, too,
but data binding is one
of our responsibilities.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I started writing
Kotlin last week,
and I felt that it
felt oddly familiar,
and I thought that's
because I spent
the last year doing code reviews
of our iOS Developer in Swift.
So I was wondering if you could
comment on the relationship
between Kotlin and Swift.
MAXIM SHAFIROV: We
are independent.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
There is a lot of
resemblance, I guess,
because we are aiming
for the same task to be--
to make it productive
developers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
meant conceptually.
Thank you.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Max is quite modest.
He actually was one of the key
folks who contributed language.
Henri Breslov is
probably here now,
who's also very,
very significant,
and is a lead language designer.
I talk too much, don't I?
One fact that Dave and I
were just talking about
is Kotlin does predate Swift.
In fact, the first announcement
about Kotlin was in 2011,
and the first
release was in 2012.
The language has
evolved since then.
So it's just an
interesting fact.
It's good to know.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I personally think that
being open and open source
is one of the most
important powers of Android.
And one of the most important
announcements for me this week
was that the Firebase SDKs
are being open sourced.
And unfortunately Android SDK is
not currently but will follow.
So the question is, what
about Google Play Services,
is there a plan to--
because Firebase Android
SDK and the Play Services
are so integrated.
So Firebase can be open source
now, but why not Play Services?
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: I think--
so the thing about Play
Services is that there's
lots of stuff in there.
Some of it is developer
focused and some of it
is just really extension
of applications,
like Google's own applications.
And so the sort of Google
policy with their applications
is they're just not open source.
The challenge is there's
no easy way in GMS core
to sort of say, hey, this
is a developer component
and this is an extension
of an app component.
So yeah, also we don't have
anyone from the GMS core--
Play Services team here.
So I can punt the question.
CHET HAASE: We punt
the questions to you.
So if you're going
to punt the question,
I don't know what to do with it.
DAVE BURKE: I'll go
into an infinite loop.
CHET HAASE: Moving on.
DAVE BURKE: Moving on.
CHET HAASE: All right, let
me go to a theoretical thing.
What's the one piece of advice
you would like developers
to never ever follow
when making Android apps?
Anybody?
DAVE BURKE: Forced
garbage collection?
I don't know.
CHET HAASE: Thread.sleep
in the ondraw method?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
WALLE: There's an application
context for everything.
CHET HAASE: Moving on.
You.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So we saw the
introduction in I/O
of a bunch of really great new
performance profiling tools.
For example, for
network and for CPU.
One thing that's
still kind of missing
is a good battery profiler
for our applications.
We do have Battery Stats
and Battery Historian,
but they're extremely difficult
to use and to interpret
the results from.
And I was wondering if
battery profiling for our apps
is something that we might
be able to look forward to?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I think--
yeah, so-- that's a
very good question.
And one of the things
we talked about
was that the battery
profiling really has
to be based on CPU and network.
We want to look at
those two things
as really important
inputs, and so we
felt like it was important
to do CPU and network first.
So those were our
initial profilers.
We don't talk about
futures, but I
will say that we get
a lot of questions
about battery profiling.
So you can read that
however you want.
DAVE BURKE: That's
code for staff
and team are working on it.
CHET HAASE: So Aurash, do you
know about the Play Dashboard
stuff that was going on?
Wasn't battery one of the stats
you were talking about there?
AURASH MAHBOD:
Yeah, so we're going
to start showing system help
information within the Play
console.
The team has been
hard at work at this,
and it's going to include
everything from crashes
to memory usage to--
is that right, Ben?
Battery?
BEN POLESZ: Well,
what we put out
there was
[? stuck wake locks, ?]
which is a big battery
drain on the system,
the number of wake-ups that are
happening in your application,
and then also information
about janky frame.
So if your
application is running
and it's really
high CPU intensive,
you'll get
information about that
to fix those issues,
both the very short jank
events and the really
severe horrible jank events
that we named after our
vice president behind us
that we call internally a Davey.
And I'm glad I found an
opportunity to talk about it.
So thank you so much
for that question.
You're famous.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Steve from SA Developers,
and I have a follow-up question
about Treble.
So we're very excited
about Treble, the whole--
how it's going to
help make it easier
to upgrade to new versions, but
the most exciting part for us
is the mention of more work on
open sourcing hardware drivers.
Is the work that Google is
going to be doing mostly
focused on the
existing projects,
like [INAUDIBLE]
and Lima, or are you
going to be working
more to start
new projects with
existing vendors
and get their code open sourced?
DAVE BURKE: We've been just
focused on the architecture.
I mean, that's really up to the
silicon vendors and the device
makers.
So we just wanted
to make sure we
had a much nicer architecture.
We haven't really put thought
into that specific aspect
of it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Next.
AUDIENCE: All right,
hey, everyone.
So last year at I/O there was
a really excellent session
on attention and notifications
and treating people well.
I was wondering-- so since we
saw that manifest this year
through notification channels
and through attention-based
notification sorting, are there
any other issues like that
on the platform that you--
are near and dear to your
heart that you wish developers
kind of spent more
time thinking about?
BEN POLESZ: Why applications
need permissions.
We get that a lot
internally about--
they understand the
premise but not necessarily
what the entire application
is doing with that data.
And so that's
something that I would
love to see developers
take a lot of care
about asking in context, and
we found when it's in context,
users understand better why
they are giving you something,
they are more inclined to
give it to you if the answer
or if the context is good and
they understand the value.
So I always put a
lot of time into that
because users appreciate it.
RACHEL GARB: And I'd
broaden that even
more to settings in general.
We know from
foundational research
that users get
pretty overwhelmed
by the number of
settings and being
able to find what they need at
the moment that they need it.
So apps should really think
about every single setting
that they want to introduce,
and is it really necessary?
Can a smart choice be
made that will satisfy
a majority of the users?
We think about that too
on the platform level,
and we have to keep
thinking about that.
It gets more
complicated over time.
DAN SANDLER: And every new
feature, every new setting,
every new thing
we add to Android
stands atop 10
things we didn't add.
And that's-- it's a huge part of
how we design things and how we
want to encourage
apps to do things.
And honestly, every
year we add new stuff,
we've probably already
just launched the stuff
that users are going
to find terrible
and that we're going to
come back and fix next year.
So we keep ourselves
in business.
AURASH MAHBOD: I'll add on.
So I think APK size
is another one.
A lot of our users, given
our global footprint,
have lower-end devices.
And I think-- those
might not always
be the users that
monetize the best,
but they also can't
afford to upgrade.
So I think it's really important
as a developer community
that we kind of band
together and really improve
our apps on those
low-end devices,
both from an APK size standpoint
and from a RAM user standpoint.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: I'm going to
put words in Tim's mouth
and say that he wants everyone
to care more about performance
as well.
So some of the stuff--
some of the sessions here
as well as some of the tools
that we're talking about
are coming out because we want
it to be easier for developers
to actually chase
that information
so that they can
fix it for users.
Am I allowed to
provide an answer?
Somebody else like
to say that instead?
Is that good?
All right.
OK.
You.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I get the sense that you guys
really like Kotlin a lot,
and I'm wondering if you
have any future plans
to implement platform framework
components using Kotlin,
and if so, would
you expose SDK APIs?
MIKE CLERON: Well,
as has been said,
we are also committed to
Java and just pragmatically
the bazillion lines of code
that we already have as Java.
So I think as much
as we love it,
the reality is
we're probably going
to be continuing to produce
Java code for the near future.
At the point where
we're starting
to introduce new
features in Kotlin,
it's going to be
something that we
make sure is 100% compatible
with Java programming language
too.
So it's going to
be something that's
going to take us a while
to adopt internally.
The first thing you'll
probably see from us
is that we'll make sure
that our Java programming
language APIs--
the legacy ones
that we already have
and the new ones that we
create interoperate perfectly
with Kotlin.
So that's going to be
a goal from us starting
from now going forward.
CHET HAASE: I should clarify
that bazillion lines of code
was just an estimate.
It's actually far more.
MIKE CLERON: It's
technically 1.036 bazillion.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yesterday I went to a talk
about progressive web apps,
and these guys are
really catching up.
So should I invest my time
learning JavaScript or Kotlin?
ROMAIN GUY: So Kotlin--
so JavaScript back in--
you can write Kotlin
[INAUDIBLE] to JavaScript.
So you can do both.
AURASH MAHBOD: I'll
take a stab it.
So I think the way
to think about PW
is-- progressive web apps--
is really if your company is
already focused on building a
flagship product on mobile web,
I think it's unrealistic
for you to go and say,
let's pivot that
entire team to get them
focused on app development.
Obviously everyone on the stage
here is an Android diehard,
and we're really focused on
improving the-- both the SDK
and the operating system.
And what we want to do
is say if you're really
focused on building a
native app experience
and you believe that's where it
converts best for your users,
then we want to make
it as easy as possible
for you to get those users
onto your app experience,
both from a developer
standpoint and
from a reachability standpoint.
CHET HAASE: Next.
AUDIENCE: What are
some great new things
you think have been overlooked
or were left out of I/O
this year for some reason?
CHET HAASE: So what
are things that we
decided to not talk about
that we would talk about now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or things that--
well, I mean--
DAVE BURKE: I mean, the
biggest one is Project Treble,
like, that is enormous.
What else?
Did we talk about
downloadable fonts, emoji?
That's kind of cool
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
DAVE BURKE: Talked about that.
We can talk about it
again, but yeah, we did--
DAVE BURKE: Did we talk
about the garbage collector,
that it went down from--
CHET HAASE: Tomorrow.
DAVE BURKE: --two points--
CHET HAASE: --is the
session on garbage--
DAVE BURKE: Well, am I
going to steal the thunder
if I mention it, how cool
it is, how fast it is?
Did you know that we
used to only garbage
collect when processes
were in the background,
but now that it's so
fast we garbage collect
in the foreground?
It's super cool.
But I am stealing Brian's
thunder, so I'll stop now.
And also Dex code layout,
did we talk about that?
Is that your thunder?
It's been stolen.
OK, so I'll stop
stealing his thunder.
You should go to the
art talk tomorrow.
It's cool stuff.
CHET HAASE: I have a
hard time believing
you guys fit everything
into all your presentations.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So our app is
localized in about 50
languages, and we also
have a lot of resources
that are localized as well.
Is there any
thought around being
able to conditionally download
those resources as opposed
to addressing them all in one
massive resource definition?
The purpose of a
smaller app basically.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah,
Google definitely
has that problem
with their apps,
and it's something
we're aware of.
There's-- I'm not going to
talk about future stuff.
There is split APKs that we
introduced in the platform in L
that's not being used yet.
And we are kind of setting
up to address that problem,
but nothing right now.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROMAIN GUY: I have an answer
for the previous question.
It's something my team did.
I should have thought about it.
Updateable graphics drivers.
We now in O have the ability
to update the graphics drivers
from the Play Store.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Is Volley still
the recommended networking
solution?
ROMAIN GUY: [INAUDIBLE]
is not here.
Can we say no?
YIGIT BOYAR: So in the
architecture components,
we recommend using retrofits.
We already use [INAUDIBLE].
That's what we say.
So also if you are
doing image loading,
we think Glide is a
very nice library,
but these are recommendations.
That's it.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
We did have one more
important question online,
and then we'll close it down.
It was, my app crashes
with null pointer exception
when the user rotates
the phone while a network
request is happening.
Do you have any plans to fix?
YIGIT BOYAR: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: Thank you.